[Music]
in persona 5 there are over a hundred
personas to collect each with their own
distinct skills and affinities but you
can't harness their strength if you lack
the skills to convince them to join your
cause
effectively negotiating with a shadow
requires finesse as you need a thorough
understanding of their personality and
temperament to win their favor
that's why we've compiled tips and
tricks to help take your shadow
communication skills to the next level
if you enjoyed this persona 5 video give
us a like and subscribe to our YouTube
channel for more guides and be sure to
check out our history of persona video
in order to negotiate you need to
trigger a holdup this only occurs when
all shadows in the field have been
knocked down to initiate a holdup use
skills that exploit a shadows weakness
it's also possible to weaken an enemy
with a critical hit whether it's from
fire ice physical electrical or even gun
attacks each shadow has particular
vulnerabilities for example an incubus
is weak to gunfire a shadows weakness is
not revealed to you until you discover
it yourself so make sure to experiment
with your skills whenever you meet one
you've never fought before a successful
blow to a shadows weakness temporarily
renders it defenseless which gives your
party ample time to surround it this
also grants your current character in
extra turn ideally to weaken another
shadow once you've knocked down all
opponents in battle a holdup begins and
you're given two choices for what to do
talk or all-out attack highlight the
shadow you wish to negotiate with and
press X to start a negotiation you're
then given three options lend me your
power give me some money and I want an
item asked to offer you its power be
mindful that you cannot convince a
shadow that is higher in level than you
to join your team doing so causes it to
flee however it's still possible to ask
for money or items when you talk to a
shadow it asks you two questions for
each you're given three responses to
choose from depending on how you answer
its questions the shadow will either
like you feel indifferent towards you or
heavily dislike you its interest in you
is determined
how well your replies accommodate its
personality type there are a total of
four types gloomy irritable timid and
upbeat you can decipher what personality
a shadow has by analyzing it mid-battle
or observing its type on the top left
portion of the screen during a holdup to
get each shadow personality type to like
you simply answer its questions in the
way it likes gloomy shadows like vague
cryptic answers though they loathe
serious and comical replies irritable
shadows favor serious answers so they
aren't fans of people who talk to
vaguely or kindly timid shadows
appreciate kindness prefer few aren't
too vague or comical with them upbeat
shadows love jokesters anyone to self
serious or vague is a complete downer in
their book often times finding the right
dialogue response can be easy to
decipher but there are times when the
correct choice might seem ambiguous or
obtuse when in doubt follow these rules
and go with your gut it's important to
note that if you've already acquired a
specific persona and are holding it up
you can skip the negotiation entirely
and get it for free which is a great way
to obtain a persona if you don't want to
summon one from your compendium while
it's possible to survive by paying
attention to the likes and dislikes of
each shadow personality type there are
actually ways to enhance your
negotiation skills further here are two
unique ways to better your chances
if you increase your relationship with
on to rank two you obtain an ability
called girls talk which gives you a
second chance when you fail a
negotiation to get this ability increase
your knowledge to two and offer to take
her out on a date while many of your
party members obtain similar or
equivalent abilities as you increase
your rank with them you get ons much
sooner
even so make sure to rank up your bond
with other party members to increase the
number of people in your crew that can
help you negotiate another way to
enhance your negotiation skills is to
take on the Sun social link which
unlocks the ability to obtain a persona
without the need for negotiation as well
as options that allow you to obtain rare
items more money and recruit persona
higher and level than you to do so talk
to toto noski yoshida the politician
outside the Shibuya train station but in
order to start the social link you need
to get a part-time job that nearby beef
ball restaurant once you've worked there
twice Yoshida will speak to you at the
end of your shift you then build your
relationship with him by holding a sign
advertising his political campaign these
are our tips to help you become a better
negotiator but is there anything you
think we missed let us know in the
comments below and for more persona 5
coverage including our full review be
sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
[Music]